i'm david alvarez i play bernardo i'm
ariana dubose anita i'm rachel zegler
and i play maria we're the cast of west
side story and today we're gonna find
out which west side story character we
actually are this is gonna look very
interesting
[Music]
how would your friends describe you
strong kind protective romantic
confident or wise you have a little bit
of everything but i would say like
definitely
[Laughter]
i don't think they have any options for
me no you're just gonna think you're
protected
i'm protected
i'll be protective sure i'm gonna get
bernardo
well then we'll know i chose i chose
confidence
what's wrong with being confident
there you go demi lovato we love we love
them we love them choose a song from
west side story
tonight america la boring
i feel pretty somewhere cool tonight
because that was my favorite song to
perform on set it's good that you didn't
pick like one of your own songs like if
i picked it i feel pretty that would
have been there
narcissism yeah
that's why i'm gonna pick america that's
why i'm gonna pick up
[Music]
what was your favorite subject in school
literature math
gym
art
history science history i was also a
history girl yeah yeah shout out to mr
ward pick another movie musical
adaptation in the heights the prom hey
dear evan hansen hairspray dream girls
or tick tick boom dream girls i'm a tick
tick boom fan i have been for a very
long time rales varsa my homeboy and
obviously lynn directed mm-hmm bradley
whitford played the late great steve
sondheim we love honestly the whole tick
tick boom of it all is really really
great fantastic the song therapy
yeah
i feel like i'm in class a narcissist
land because i feel like the prom i
don't think that's classic narcissism no
it's not because you're not like making
your specific performance in the problem
and it just says pick another picture it
just says pick another yeah it doesn't
have to be your favorite pick
i did it the problem okay
oh i picked dream girls
okay
but i did pick it
amazing pick something important from
west side story maria's dress
the balcony scene
doc's drug store the dance at the gym
new york the choreography
i love my nueva york i know i was there
too yeah but i do think the choreography
is very important
[Music]
justin peck that's true
choreographer patricia delgado
craig salstein
finally pick your favorite movie theater
snack popcorn soda cookies chocolate
chips chicken fingers this is a trick
bag because you can't pick two and i'm a
sweet and salty person are you a popcorn
and m m's girl i'm actually a popcorn
and um what are they called the
chocolate-covered raisins oh raise your
nuts raisins yeah i'm back not person
i know raisins
okay
can i get another one
but i'm a traditional popcorn gal
yeah
this is annoying
results are in i'm tony i'm anita i'm
maria
oh my god are you guys
that's weird class a narcissist that's
really weird i should not be tony
well i kind of love that for you though
yeah i'm an undercover you're an
undercover tony
so when you see west side story on
december 10th in theaters
like anita you are strong and deeply
passionate you will always speak up for
what you believe in you also have a huge
heart and all you want for yourself and
your loved ones is peace world peace
like tony you're working on yourself and
committed to becoming a better you you
wear your heart on your sleeve and you
can just sense that there's something
coming for you
[Laughter]
and open you let yourself feel the
excitement giddiness and joy of new
experiences and new love you feel pretty
and you're not afraid to tell the world
[Music]
i'll take it okay i like that i like her
we do we like her she can stay she can
speak
see west side story only in theaters
december 10th bye guys thanks buzzfeed
thanks buzzfeed
good job guys
yeah